[Music]
this
is breaking news on eight news now
now at five governor steve sisselak has
tested positive for covid19 that
announcement coming into our newsroom
about an hour ago i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez the governor says he
underwent routine testing today
and a rapid test did give him that
positive result
our vanessa murphy is following the
story and has more details for us
tonight vanessa
governor siselek is currently in
quarantine at the governor's mansion
up north he says he does not currently
have covet 19 symptoms but
he did previously feel fatigued he
thought he was just tired
he has a busy schedule now he gets
tested
at least once a week though his last two
tests on november 6
and november 2nd came back negative the
latest test with the positive results as
you mentioned
is a rapid test he's still waiting for
the results of a pcr test which does not
provide
immediate results now because of the
positive test the governor will be
checking in with a physician regularly
a spokeswoman says his wife tested
negative for covid19
the governor personally called other
close contacts at this time
staff from the governor's office will
also be in quarantine
earlier this week sisilak attended a
ribbon cutting and also he held a press
conference
about a spike in covid 19 cases
in our state now the governor made a
post on facebook he says he's using this
as an opportunity to remind nevadans to
stay home
and he referred to the numbers in nevada
the more than
1800 new cases identified in nevada
yesterday
and he says cases are growing at a rate
of 1.3 percent
or about 1400 new cases
per day now it appears the governor is
one of these new cases
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now